thanks Bill so I'm going to talk to you
a little bit about supply chains
evolving supply chains it was like
nineteen ninety i gave a talk to the in
ontario wheat board there was a
marketing talk they wanted to know how
to get higher price for their wheat and
i still have to differentiate I said
tell me what's special about Ontario
wheat and they said nothing I said well
surely the wind comes across from the
east or the west I don't care where it
comes from it must come from somewhere
and they said you don't understand all
wheat is the same well if you're trying
to get an extra margin out of your wheat
that's not the way to go this is why
these are called commodities is because
of the mental set that it's all the same
and this was the mental set for a long
time and in a way I'm here to tell you
that that's changing one reason it's
changing is because of increasing
traceability that's enabled by
technology so traceability clearly is
important in with Z coli outbreak people
are potentially dying you want to know
where that lettuce or where those
tomatoes came from traceability can help
you figure out that farm and whatever
one of the rises of non commodity is
GMOs where for the first time I can say
literally the first time but in the
grand scheme of things for the first
time people got very fussy about what
kind of grain they were getting is the
GMO is it not GMO the Europeans taking
the charge and so agriculture traders
had to start separating separating to
once you start separating when you get
the hang of separating you can keep
doing it consumers have played a role
consumers some consumers want organic
how do we know this stuff actually is
organic did it come from so now you have
to install inspecting farms people want
sustainability people want work of
welfare but you're in order to obviously
you just look at the grain you can't
tell that so you have to go back and
start inspecting so suddenly there's a
move to understanding where this crop
has actually come from and retailers now
go and inspect farms or they have agents
inspecting farms once you start caring
where the stuff comes from then you
actually start talking to farmers which
is a miracle but that leads to retailers
for example manufacturers actually
buying from specific farmers once you
start inspecting you start realizing
who's doing well who's not doing well so
Tesco for 25 years whatever it was lived
by essentially buying from the cheapest
i've been maligning them slightly but
buying from the cheapest but these days
they have specific relationships with
farmers and so the environment has
changed I won't say everything I
couldn't give you a percentage of what
is still traders commodity and what is
not trained in as commodity but the
trend is in that direction tesco is not
the only one having direct relationships
with farmers china is having direct
relationships with farmers china
obviously a big buyer of shouldn't say
commodities commodities so they're
trying to do long-term deals with
fondants with cops they're trying to buy
land in South America and Africa so
instead of relying on just buying from
the pool I'm even if even if I'm Terry
we was any different was different from
somebody else's when it gets transported
it sort of gets all put in the same
container as everybody else's they'd all
just lost now thinking of China and
thinking of buying grain another
developer
in supply chains which should be with us
for a long time as food security
self-sufficiency in the 80s and the 90s
when the whole world seemed to be going
to we're all in this together kind of
thing agriculture was too and then we
had then we had the kind of food crisis
of 2008 that's a period when prices shut
up country suddenly started to realize
that food security was a non trivial
issue that's something that should
really be thinking about or thinking
again that it was an important topic if
you're Japan these days you import sixty
percent of your food that too he seems
like too much and over we could go
around the room but you're an island I
mean if you can tell I'm English British
as a youngster I heard about the massive
losses that the British were making in
there nationalized shipbuilding industry
second world war Britain decided it was
in this strategic interest to be able to
build its own shares I won't dwell but
you know if you're Japan and you're
importing sixty percent of your food the
scenes does seem like a security issue a
trade is going up international trade is
going up again going back to China with
its constraints of land and water it
makes sense to be importing large
amounts of food currently at some soy
beans but meat so they make a lot of
sense meat from South America those
trade lines are quite long and you might
start to get a little worried about it
but the question of whether supply chain
when you think about the future is the
supplied other supply chains going to be
increasing Intercontinental II or not
and a lot of it depends on the political
climate but presumably the economic
solution is that yes the other issue in
supply chains I'd like to talk about is
a problem I talk described as correlated
risk farming has always been kind of
risky business
the factories outside is the way I like
to think about it you know you've got
whether you've got pests but these are
diversify diversify bull risks across
the country if it country is big enough
across the world certainly you know you
know your good weather and I'm having
bad weather that's something but does it
but now there are what I call demand
risks I mean one commander is is China
suddenly stops importing when they have
a huge proportion of the traded
commodities but there are other examples
my the one that I was sticks in my mind
is doc cracking saying we should be
eating bread or carbohydrates and my
mind is like everybody stops eating
bread the next day yeah this is a real
problem or somebody says that you can
now eat eggs you know so suddenly
everyone's rushing out and it's this
communication thing that's making
everybody act in the same way I mean
there are bigger issues in the world of
this coordinated behavior than just
agribusiness but it's something that's
affecting agribusiness so my message is
that maybe 30 years seems like a long
time to you but in 30 years the supply
chains have evolved a lot to match
consumer tastes to match the
capabilities of Technology they'll be
developing further if you want my
opinion on it I mean I think the
productivity of agribusiness is such
that I don't really think we as a globe
need to worry about starving but I think
the question is particularly with this
of demand risk and so on so forth is
whether the volatility in prices will
increase
you